Hello! Welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips.
This month, we're looking at a tricky subject.
Conflict.
Now often in business, we have hot conflict situations.
How can we make these constructive or productive?
One approach is the interest-based relational approach.
What this means is...
...two key points.
First, separate interests from positions.
Position is what somebody is saying.
The interest is the underlying reason behind it.
Often the conflict is because of positions clashing.
If you understand the interests,...
...often you can reach a compromise.
For example, say two small children are fighting over a pumpkin.
Now, both of them want the pumpkin. That's their positions.
However, if I taunt them,...
...I find out one wants just the inside to bake a pumpkin pie.
The other wants just the outside to make a jack-o'-lantern for Halloween.
So, by understanding the interests, I can help them solve the conflict.
Second, relationship.
Focus on keeping a good relationship...
...by using active listening, showing understanding and respect to the other person.
These are two techniques to help make conflict constructive.
Thank you and good luck!